foreign
how can we help
hey thanks for taking my call you bet
what's going on
yeah so my question is how do I navigate
being like a Ramsay listener trusting
your advice on money and being a
mortgage loan officer I asked this
because I put people into mortgages that
do not align with what I would do I
offer helocs all of it that you don't
recommend while I don't do any of these
things how do I get them to people who
ask without feeling guilty
hmm it's a good question and and we've
I've received this question on the show
many times uh and it's it's um first of
all you're not doing anything morally or
ethically wrong let's start there can
you can you acknowledge that
yeah okay so you're in an industry where
again if you don't feel like long term
your values are aligning aligning then
then I think at some point you begin to
make the exit don't you don't need to
jump right away because again you're not
doing anything morally legally ethically
wrong there's just a disconnect when you
see people take out things that you go
this is not good for them but you can't
say that because then you lose your job
and so I think my first reaction to this
is don't jump
Let's Line something else up and let's
do work that that we enjoy but also that
produces a result that aligns with our
values and that's what's happening right
now so I don't want you to beat yourself
up is what I'm saying but eventually
this is going to wear on you and could
create some resentment certainly a toxic
attitude in yourself and so I would
begin to be looking at what can I do
that I align with and the other piece of
this is
we need some good guys out there too
Adam and you're one of the good guys
that's right and so there's nothing
wrong with saying hey you know what I'm
going to pass those loans off to someone
else or I'm going to educate the
customer on my feelings about this and
if they still want to go through with it
at least I can sleep easy at night
but if they are dead set on taking out
the HELOC I'm gonna try to serve them
well as they go through this and educate
them and go hey here's what you need to
know about the HELOC here's why I don't
think it may be the right choice for you
and at least then you have your morals
intact and you're not swindling someone
into something but again in the mortgage
industry there's a lot of mortgages we
don't agree with and we've I've got a
lot of friends that are mortgage loan
officers and you know we're fans of the
15-year fixed rate mortgage might they
sell someone a 30-year mortgage because
that's what the customer wants
that's part of the job and so if that's
something that is going to eat you
inside like Ken said then I think it's
time to switch to a different industry
entirely or find a different role
yeah it's just because my parents are
realtors so ever since
um I got my license
um the idea was that all of their
clients would do their financing through
me
so it's just we have our own like you
know place now where it's at a One-Stop
shop for real estate and it works out
really well like that and I just when I
first was getting into it I never
thought that this would even be an issue
because it's just so perfect and you
know it's great money and everything but
I just wish I wasn't so like encumbered
in the Ramsey Way
because it just it is you know it
doesn't like ignorance was Bliss before
this and now I just know how terrible of
an idea this stuff is what do you think
about what George said though Adam I
thought his good guy strategy was pretty
good certainly since your parents are
sending these people your way and so if
you're going look I know you want this
but let me just walk you through every
side of this deal and you give them
perspective
yeah see I
I wish I could you know do that with
like if I had a lot of clients I mean
anyone that I get from them if I were to
turn them away I would lose that like
relationship with me I don't think we
said anything about turning them away
the idea was is just helping them see
what the best vehicle is for them long
term
which alone is the best for them
right okay
yeah it's yeah here's the deal we've
covered this from every side and I could
tell you're wrestling with this and my
point is is that if you can't get to a
place where you feel good about this you
need to move on in the future that
that's the takeaway
uh because George it'll eat him up it'll
just weigh on him and it's just not
necessary well in the financial industry
is a tough one to be in if you say hey I
have this very specific view of money
but I work at a bank and Banks sell debt
products Banks sell credit cards but
guess what we also need good morally
valued people working in those Banks to
serve customers and so I don't think
you're a bad person for being in this if
you stay there but again if it's
something that's going to affect you
personally at some point it's not worth
the money and I'd rather you go make a
little bit less for now as you go find a
different career path of something that
you can really go I feel really good
that I serve that person well today
yeah because again here's what will
happen
you will just make yourself miserable I
don't care what it is you know you could
do you could have you could be in a in
what I would call The Sweet Spot where
you're using what you do best do what
you love to produce results that matter
to you
and you're in an environment where you
feel like
the leadership is unethical
uh they've done something that you
really disagree with
and it just kind of they smoothed it
over they swept it under the carpet I
don't care what the situation is when
there is a a sizable disconnect in your
values
um it's different than putting up with a
problem employee or a teammate or even a
boss is just not great but they don't
they're not abusive to you this is a
this is a character ethical excuse me
not ethical this is a character or
values based conversation and when it is
so opposed to what you believe you won't
be able to grit your teeth and bear it
for very long I mean it's one reason all
I can't sell cars because I know the
people walking in there right are going
to want to do it and they don't have the
money and I'm gonna have to walk them
through the payments and the debt I
couldn't sleep at night and so I
wouldn't be in that industry because of
my values yeah good stuff hey thanks for
the call Adam you're a good good young
man appreciate the call it's a good call
I think you know what you need to do
let's just do it wisely it's not making
any big jumps